allá dél parajón lo encarcelaron en
septiembre meses después su padre
denuncia las precarias condiciones en
las que ha estado detenido desde que el
gobierno de daniel ortega lo acusó por
cargos relacionados con su cavar la
integridad nacional porque no miran en
muchacho lo único que yo tengo que se
llama hallar los ángeles para un
gutiérrez secuestrado preso por la
policía el chipote la policía del rey no
puede vamos a hacer como el caso de
yader son muchos los opositores del
régimen de ortega que fueron
encarcelados antes de las elecciones de
noviembre de 2021 que le garantizaron un
quinto mandato ahora más de 40 están
siendo juzgados tras ser señalados por
presunta violación a la constitución
atentar contra la integridad nacional o
haber recibido financiamiento extranjero
para cometer delitos de lavado de dinero
bienes y activos mientras tanto sus
familiares exigen nuevamente la
liberación de los suyos con el apoyo de
la oea afirman que los que consideran
como presos políticos han sido sometidos
a aislamientos interrogatorios
constantes la comida insuficiente como
la asegura la madre ya observado en
prisión desde noviembre del año pasado
este detenido y con condiciones
tan precarias verdad como el estado
está en una celda pequeñita con nueve
personas y ahí éste tiene que acomodar
varias ongs han criticado los juicios
catalogándolos de ilegítimos y como una
herramienta de intimidación a la
población sabemos qué bueno que el
régimen probablemente la va a condenar
verdad a través de muchas puertas
cerradas a través de un juicio que
violenta el principio de publicidad
ortega se posicionó en enero para su
cuarto mandato consecutivo tras haber
recibido
75% de los votos unas elecciones
marcadas por la persecución y el
encarcelamiento de opositores y
precandidatos y ampliamente rechazadas
por la comunidad internacional